[Music]
[Music]
hi
i'm thomas anderson
like many of you i work with computers i
like the freedom i feel outside the
limitations of the real world
but computers are also mirrors
reflecting back who and what we are in
the choices we make
the worlds we build
they also confront us with questions
about why we want to choose this or that
why we want to make x instead of a y
where do ideas of who we are and what we
want even come from
you take the red pill
and i show you how deep the rabbit hole
goes
[Applause]
this isn't real
what is real
how do you define real
for instance i'm not even sure why i'm
here
i remember waking up and thinking that
i'm supposed to come here
that it was important for me to ask
people
how do we know what is real
hi i'm keanu reeves
over 20 years ago i first played the
character thomas anderson in the matrix
trilogy those films pioneered digital
cinema with shots like bullet time back
then we talked a lot about where the
digital age might take cinema and
narrative
in an industry where actors have tried
to remain perpetually young
we wondered about digital faces that
could become immortal
hi i'm carrie anne moss and i play
trinity in the matrix films 20 years ago
we asked ourselves how long it would be
before faces and bodies could be changed
as easily as we change clothes
we wondered what would identity mean in
a completely digital world
and what would reality mean
when a world we can build feels as real
as our own
[Applause]
yeah this is
what they wanted
they said they were fine with your
theoretical mumbo jumbo but they needed
some sexy action
the marketing people
marketing
i thought we were supposed to have total
creative control
welcome to the matrix
wow
you still got it
like riding a bike they say
i sometimes miss this version of us
me too
the hell are you doing back there
sorry i was told this is a sim preparing
me to fight the system
right on
you know about this yeah
it's all supposed to be a little
unreal
word of advice agents are bad
but whatever you do stay the hell away
from marketing
see you soon
[Music]
so
what now
haven't you ever watched a movie before
the tires
say no more
you drive i'll shoot
so
sorry
boys course they have a helicopter
[Applause]
hang on
still honest
up
it's ahead to be safer
just don't give up
you boys are gonna get a kick out of
this
too many of them
you again
hold daddy
hell yeah
what are you doing
time to blow this box down
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
you